but yeah then kind of the the Virgin
Mary kind of appears
um you know oddly in this very masculine
way at the end is as kind of this Apex
figure within this kind of spiritual
test
um and she's kind of she's kind of like
yeah she's pretty terrifying there's
something pretty scary yeah but that's
okay you have definitely have traditions
in the Orthodox Church itself about you
know aspects of the Virgin which are
are kind of terrifying like she's the
protector too like she has this she
protects her child so there's something
about that you know you you take a icons
of the Virgin on the wall of
Constantinople when the wall when the
city is being attacked you know there's
something about that there's a there is
a kind of mother bear aspect to the to
the to the Virgin as well
foreign
[Music]
this is Jonathan Petro
welcome to the symbolic world
[Music]
hello everybody I'm really excited to be
here with Brandon Dayton Brandon is an
artist I know mostly as a as a graphic
novelist he made a he he wrote a book
which if you follow me on social media
you see me shared quite a few times it's
called the green Monk and uh it's a
really beautiful graphic novel about a
young uh it's a a young boy who is finds
himself in a Russian Monastery and
there's a whole kind of fantastic story
which surrounds the graphic novel it's
very it's very beautiful and Airy the
story is kind of told through the
succession of panels and it uh it
doesn't need a lot of words it really is
this kind of beautiful flow of story so
I'm really happy to have them with me to
be able to talk about about the graphic
novel and his his Inspirations what
would brought him to make it so Brandon
thanks for talking to me yeah super
super happy to be here
and so tell us a little bit about what
was the
what was the impetus behind this book
oh man that's such a good question
because there are like there's always
like little ideas that bubble up that
are interesting ideas or images you know
um and so there's I can like Trace
different threads of like very early on
having this idea of like a blade of
grass as a sword and then having some
sort of I remember at some point
having it be some sort of like my chance
to to do Star Wars the way I wanted to
do it I'm going to be like okay I'm
gonna tell the story of Star Wars I want
to tell it but I'm going to put it in
this other fantasy and instead of
lightsabers it's going to be like this
like
um grass sword
and that kind of faded away but then
um when I was introduced to um
tarkovsky's Andre rublev that was like
when things kind of clicked and this is
like going way back to college like as
this is like first time I saw that was
in college and I had this character and
I was like oh yeah I want to put this
character in that world and that's where
things like really started to fall
together like come together for me
um but then there is also like you talk
about impetus and then there's just like
a feeling there's a certain feeling
about a story that starts to emerge and
there was something about this character
and like what this character represented
to me that just really got to the core
of like what really mattered to me you
know I mean if I could put it in in
other terms it felt there was something
that felt like sacred about it to me
like
um an actual member I was uh this is
actually I was I was finally finally out
of it takes me a long time to to make
art so this is like I was out of college
and I was I was newly married and going
through like therapy and I remember
having this thing where I was like I
have all these ideas all these stories I
want to do I don't know what to do with
my life at that point I was like wanting
to make movies and and thinking about
doing screenplays and I remember going
through this process with this therapist
um
where it was kind of like well yeah but
which of these things like really are
you most drawn to or feels like most
important and meaningful to you and it
was like oh yeah I have this story about
this Monk and
um I really feel like it has to be a
comic book you know
um and so once I landed on that I'm like
oh yeah this is this is what like I
really feel it's like warmth in my heart
about this thing
I kind of put everything to the side
and I was like okay no more trying to
make movies I'm just gonna make this
comic book and see what happens and that
was the very first mini comic and then
so the very first mini comic of green
monk was was the product of that
and so how what was the reaction because
I guess you came back to it a little bit
later to the same story and kind of put
it back together yeah so I mean I've
been trying to I mean I wanted to to be
a big famous amazing artist Storyteller
in some way so I'd always been like
trying to make art and putting it out on
the internet and stuff and I'd been to
conventions and nothing really ever
connected
and then I made this book
and I started going to connect
conventions with it and things like that
and the response to it was like
fantastic it's like more than I could
have expected I was like oh wow this is
so yeah if you like kind of follow your
heart do this stuff it seems like most
important they'll be a good response so
it's to this day it's the thing that
sold the best at conventions I mean I
remember I'd go to conventions and I'd
sell like 60 copies of this and this is
as me being an artist no one knew about
you know I had no name no previous
experience with comics and I would I for
me it seemed like I was selling quite a
bit of those and and I've never sold
stuff like that I have a volume of books
you know ever since then either
um but it also got
um within that time it got nominated for
uh uh y'all said the yalsa um top 10
teams for book list award and was
selected for their list in 2011. so
um that was a really cool honor because
it was
um the only self-published book on their
list that year
um and it was just cool that it got into
the hands of the right people and I had
a chance to talk with them and they were
just like yeah we really want to support
staff that's not coming from larger
larger publishers
um
so that happened but you know I was also
in the midst of
um working and trying to support a
family and whatever the next step was
there
didn't seem very obvious to me and
um I was I was working a job as a
concept artist within the video game
industry which is very demanding
um and so it was it was a big challenge
to put my energies into making art
during the day and then to try to come
home and and trying to move things
forward with the comic books you know
yeah make more art like make art in your
job and then in your spare time it's
like exhausting yeah and I'm not I've
just kind of come to realize that I'm
just not I don't have the same worth of
work ethic as other artists out there
and so it just it just like it it really
burnt me out trying to do that
um and finally I got to the point I I
was working at Disney Interactive in in
Salt Lake City
and um
I just was making tiny progress on on
the the latest book Blood of the martyrs
and I finally talked with my wife and
I'm like you know I'd like to just quit
Disney and just just work on making this
book
and so he talked about it like what
would be the best way to do it we had
some savings and my wife was like no
let's not go through the savings I'll
start working and you can work on the
book and so
um that's next I think four or five
years was me working on the book slowly
so wow
foreign
and I was dealing with all sorts of like
depression and other issues as I was
like like trying to do that
um but I at the end of the day I did
finish it
um
and uh
I was very happy with how how it turned
out and just feels like a very authentic
you know true part of myself
um and I'm kind of proud of what it is
and it was like well reviewed I mean
there's lots of people that I respect
that have that have spoken well of it
and so
um that's been great
um and so I'm curious about some of the
elements like because there are some of
the elements which are obvious in terms
of the the storytelling and there's some
which are just
it's like
how can I say this it's very mysterious
let's say some some elements of the
story are quite clear and
straightforward and some of the elements
are quite mysterious and so I'm
wondering if so for example there's a
scene with all these like giant demons
for example like these huge kind of
giant demons
um and so I was wondering if you're
pulling from certain mythologies or if
it was really just your imagination that
you were kind of pulling from
yeah with with this book The Fantastical
elements of it it's it's a much it was a
much more like kind of intuitive
um kind of imaginative imaginative thing
um there's there was definitely kind of
a flavor I wanted to that you talked
about kind of the mysterious quality of
it
um and I yeah or this kind of like
esoteric feeling
um particularly there's kind of uh some
moments where
like he's given kind of these clues or
these like messages or signs and you're
not really clear exactly what they mean
or how they fit together but it's just
it's more of like the feeling that I
wanted to get from that
[Music]
um
and kind of this like descent into
this um kind of spiritual realm I just I
really enjoyed
um and the ambiguity of like what is
like what is dream and what is reality
is something that that was was really
interesting to me as I was doing this as
well yeah and there's a there's a sense
in which the main character
is some kind it like you talked about
Star Wars it makes sense like you get a
sense in which this character is somehow
chosen but is also possibly a dark
figure no it's not clear you know it is
kind of that Luke Skywalker idea or the
Skywalker idea
um and and there's that wonderful moment
where he chooses his weapon I think
that's probably the obviously the high
moment where it almost feels like he's
being forced to become what he is right
he's he he's resisting like the whole
book He's just kind of he's resisting
one way or another certain things he
he's reacting to to different to
different things around him and then
that's the moment where even in his own
he resists like picking the weapon and
then that ultimately would lead him to
end up having the weapon that that he
didn't want to have in the first place
yeah yeah yeah
and so you did you so had you already
thought about what the sequel would be
like did you you kind of planted on your
head or you were just kind of you you
just kind of finished it and you were
you were because it feels like when it
ends like it like this book has to have
a second I know oh I know it's it's
really frustrating
because I think it's very unlikely that
a sequel is never gonna happen to this
book
I mean I understand I understand it I
mean especially if it took you it's it's
interesting that you're saying it took
you like five years to work through it
because
I can see it when you say it I can see
it because every panel
seems like it has been completely
thought out but also but it still it
doesn't feel labored at all because I
think it's probably because of your
drawing style there's something about it
which feels like it's just flowing
through like the entire story just kind
of flows through uh and the panels are
flowing almost like yeah like there's
water rolling down and you're just
you're just kind of tumbling into the
story especially with the character kind
of falling into imaginary spaces and
then coming back out and everything
there's that whole thing going on
yeah talking to you really makes me want
to make comics again that's great if I
can do that that's awesome we need you
making Comics we want you making more
comics because uh it's interesting
because one of the things that is funny
to me is like how much did you know
about let's say Russian Orthodoxy before
you you made this
I knew I knew Andrew black and that was
it right right right
so I've I've read I did a little bit of
reading after that like a lot of
Wikipedia stuff
I did another little short story that's
connected kind of tangentially connected
to Green monk it actually kind of
connects the mini comic to
um to blood of the martyrs so it's kind
of the one connecting threat is this
little like four page
um story I did that's much more based on
Russian mythology it's like it's
straight out of a Russian myth that I
kind of used I had kind of two pieces
from each of this the the stories that
kind of end up in there
um so that was it yeah I did some
reading and that definitely kind of
influenced how I looked at it but
there's other things I've been learning
afterwards that have been really
interesting that have given me like more
insight onto
which sounds funny to say but you know
reading more about like
um
like kind of Eastern Orthodox traditions
of contemplative practice yep and how
that how that affected
um those communities and things like
that that have been
but
I've I've kind of said before that I'm
kind of like
I'm kind of like
um my knowledge of like Russian history
and and and religion is kind of like
similar to Sergio Leone's like
understanding of like the American West
right you know it's kind of like this
beautiful caricature let's say yeah yeah
something like that yeah
no I definitely that I mean I definitely
because I definitely got that in in the
book because I think you might not know
I'm Orthodox myself and then okay so I'm
actually an iconographer that's my Prime
let's say uh work and so it was
interesting to kind of go through and
see
your interpretation like even of the
icons and kind of how you you brought
different elements together and how you
kind of interpreted the the iconographic
tradition so I find that I found that
very fascinating uh so there's because
even like so there's a sense in which
obviously you have this feminine
character yeah that repeats let's say
through the through the story right it
starts with the boy's mother but then
appears in almost like a mythological
way and then it kind of revealed at the
end but and so were you trying to
because the sense I get is that there
was something of of the Virgin Mary in
that imagery but you're also trying to
pull in more almost like a this goddess
figure that was kind of being pulled
into the story at the same time so I'm
curious a little bit about that in terms
of that that that feminine the
repetition of that feminine character
through the story yeah yeah that's
that's interesting it's it's uh
that's the one I think that's really
exciting me about how this story worked
out and a lot of this some stuff is kind
of intentional but a lot of the stuff
afterwards you look back at it and
you're like oh my gosh this is like
seeing these huge parts of my psyche I
wasn't aware of you know because it's
very much a story about like masculinity
as far as this boy being raised in this
this Monastery and this particular form
of like spiritual masculinity you know
and I I was I was a raised Mormon so
that has okay yeah it has its own flavor
as far as like what does it mean to be a
man and be like spiritual
um so that the whole sense of like being
in being raised in a house that is a
house the fathers where you're just
surrounded by all these fatherly figures
you know
is really interesting and I've actually
been I've been criticized I mean I've
had a few people criticize me to be like
hey there's like no women in this story
you know but then it's like the feminine
is very much a part of this story as far
as like obviously his mother as this as
this figure
um this like connection this balance
between like paganism and and you know
Orthodoxy and how they kind of unite in
in his person
um but yeah then kind of the the Virgin
Mary kind of appears
um you know oddly in this very masculine
way at the end is as kind of this Apex
figure within this kind of spiritual
test
um and she's kind of she's kind of like
but that's okay you have definitely have
traditions in the Orthodox Church itself
about you know aspects of the Virgin
which are
are kind of terrifying like she's this
protector too like she has this she
protects her child so there's something
about that you know you you take a icons
of the Virgin on the wall of
Constantinople when the wall when the
city is being attacked you know there's
something about that there's a there is
a kind of mother bear aspect to the to
the to the Virgin as well yeah yeah so I
mean it's really one of these things
that as I look back on it it's so
delightful to look back on it and just
and as a map of my own like interior
world and obviously those things always
map to some sort of Greater like you
know archetypal realm whatever you want
to call it
um but yeah that's one of those
interesting things is seeing how like
the masculine and The Feminine kind of
kind of play out in it so yeah but I
think you're I think it the way that you
treat the feminine characters in it is
really
I think it's very powerful you know
because there is a sense in which right
now we're trying you know every story is
always trying to now to replace the hero
with a girl like it's like every year
you know as he replaced with a girl but
there's something about that which is
artificial and there's a there's a
missing of what the feminine can be in a
story even a story of Adventure which
has usually is a more masculine has a
more masculine Trope but you know the
image of the the woman who is there as
it's kind of hidden guiding principle
and is also like this this mysterious
agent which is pulling you forward you
know
um I always use uh the image of
Galadriel in in The Lord of the Rings
movies which it's like oh yeah he's not
she's not in she doesn't feel like she's
important in like how much presence she
has in the story but she she cuts to the
Chase and is like this like secret
figure that is motivating the characters
to go to actually go on the quest you
know and so I felt that definitely in
your book as well where this feminine
character is always hiding in the
background and is there to kind of pull
the the the boy you know into his into
becoming what he's going to be
ultimately
yeah and and her figure I mean his
mother kind of reappears as this
mystical guide like in in his visions
and um
yeah she is always kind of pulling him
away from like the realm of law like
that's kind of her like thing is he's in
this this monaster that's all about law
and you know order and all this other
stuff and she's constantly like okay
there's this other thing
um
yeah I don't know
and so you grew up you grew up you grew
up Mormon do you still consider yourself
more man or not at all yes so that's
been an interesting thing I I left the
LDS church which is kind of the largest
denomination probably about eight years
ago okay but which is a very very
painful process when you leave like a
religion but I've come to a point now
where like that identity is is really
important to me
so I I say that I I consider myself a
Mormon but it's a very like
individualistic
like way that I I Define that like it's
just this thing that like feels right
for me like in a way that connects me to
place and um you know certain people
um and I haven't I haven't like figured
out all the details of what that means
as far as like how it affects How I Live
or whatever but yeah it's something
that's still very important to me yeah
but so you don't you're not part of like
a community though you kind of live it
individually yeah yeah although I don't
know much about I don't know much about
Mormon church so so I'm just kind of
asking these questions I don't know
yeah it's it's it's one of these things
where um
like I I believe that I I feel like
Mormonism and like Mormonism is actually
like an ethnicity but it's also it's so
because of like Mennonites or yeah views
or Mennonites yeah the the way that it's
it it kind of emerged and kind of
evolved you know was very isolated in
the Rocky Mountains and it was this one
organization that really kind of like
tied everyone together this one faith
and so I think now like nowadays it's
really hard for people to separate those
two things and they'd be like oh you can
be Mormon and not be a member of this
church is is something that I don't
think people see as a possibility
um which I think is kind of a shame
because there are people that leave and
they're just like okay like what the
[__] am I now that I'm I'm not this
thing you know
um
so
I'd be interested in a community of of
of Mormons that that aren't connected to
the LDS church but I don't know what
that looks like community of ex-mormons
or like uh let's say uh individualist
Mormons or something yeah
yeah I don't know I don't know if
there's any of that exists uh for sure I
don't know so but I I'm wondering about
because I don't the the book there's
something very mystical definitely about
like just the whole uh approach of the
book and so is that something how do you
perceive that in relation to your own
path let's say to your own to to the way
that you're living out your own
yeah your own spiritual path let's say
yeah yeah I mean I I look back at it now
and it seems like there's a very clear
message in it for me that I wasn't aware
of
um and there's there's very much this
sense of I mean it comes back to kind of
this like owning owning your spiritual
path
um where you know you have this
character that's very conflicted in
trying to
trying to somehow reconcile these two
extremes that he's part of very very
much has a love for this community he's
a part of but then there's this deep
rich interior world that that
um speaks to who he is and comes out in
these like you know these violent heroic
fantasies that he has
um and then I mean the kind of end is is
very interesting too because it is kind
of like what comes next
um and there's something there in that
truth
of kind of the unknown like him walking
out into into the winter as far as you
know eventually does take responsibility
and he does like take action and even
though he's like made this vow
to never take a life he ends up you know
saving his Monastery by by you know
killing all of these Invaders
um and so that's a very exciting
question to me is like where you end up
when you decide to you know take
responsibility for for your path in life
and it's not simply like
[__] the monastery you know because for
him he's like he's still wearing his
robes it's like this still matters for
him you know
um it's interesting I was really
surprised too about the ending uh
because there's something you might not
know about the Orthodox ethos of War
which is that on the one hand in the
Orthodox tradition there's a sense in
which war violence and combat is
inevitable that it's going to happen
there is there is to some extent the
possibility that you could attain
something that there is it's not
completely devoid of of value completely
but it's also not totally sanctioned and
so for example someone who a warrior
that goes out to war when they return
from war they're they're barred from
communion for a certain amount of time
they actually have to go to confession
and they have to do Penance for their
combat but it's not like they're saying
what you did you know they're they're
recognizing the value of the combat but
they're also realizing that there's
something about it which is due to our
circumstance it's like it's due to this
Fallen World in which we are and so you
have to do some Penance and you have to
you have to atone for the killing that
you participated in so it's just
interesting because I don't think he
probably didn't know that but there's
something that comes out in the end of
the book at something like that where
it's like he doesn't want to kill
anybody he doesn't want to be violent
and then he's forced to do it out of
love for his fellow months but because
of that he it's almost like he also now
has to leave the monastery so it's like
a thing where he he saved the monastery
by by doing this uh he engages in
something which is like a trespass
so he has to be exiled but he did it for
them and so there's like it's an
interesting it definitely is in terms of
narrative it's a very powerful moment I
thought
yeah thank you that's a really
interesting interesting perspective
um when I kind of made the decision that
oh these are like pacifist monks that
was a real speculation I'm just like I
don't know if that's something that ever
existed you know within like Eastern
Orthodoxy I know it's existing monks are
not supposed to fight like that's for
sure you're not supposed to take up
weapons there have been weird exceptions
to that but the the they're definitely
are not supposed to fight yeah
yeah but then yeah the
there is also there is also at least the
archetype of like the warrior monk which
is which is yeah it's more of a that's
more of a it's definitely more of a
western archetype like the the idea of
the um
but it's funny because you have that in
your in the book don't you you have
these you have an image of these these
monks that they were Western
like Warrior monks I guess who kind of
gave up their ways to become to become
Eastern Eastern monks yeah that's right
yeah and so and so then it's like then
he so it's like you come to a point
where now this this young character
is going in that direction he's like
he's going back in that direction
yeah in terms of narrative I just
thought it was so it was so uh ripe with
uh with possibility definitely
yeah and that's one of those things
where it's just like man it's just like
a tribute to
um how important it is to follow like
intuition when you're like working
through this these things because
there's never a part of me that's just
like
here's what my morals are and I'm going
to put it down in this book but as you
work through these things it's just like
there's something about this that just
feels right and I don't I still don't
even know why like I feel like I should
be giving you an explanation about like
what it means that's okay I can I can I
can I say sometimes it's better when
someone else finds the meaning because
it's you seem like to be really an
artist in the sense you said like
artists are more like uh a lot of
artists are more they're more like
tuning Forks right yeah like they get
they get the pattern right they can tune
in to the to the Harmony and they put it
down but it's like you know you don't
necessarily know all the implications of
what that is when you do it when you're
doing it
but but I do think it speaks to
something as far as like like how I feel
about morality like in in the sense
there's a feeling in in the conclusion
just about like
morality is this living thing that you
experience and it's not necessarily like
a a list of rules
um
and it's like you like you said there's
something about what you talk about like
yes you can go to like circumstances
bring you to war but then there there
needs to be some sort of penance at the
same time for what you you're done
and kind of the complexity of of
morality it's there's something about
that that just tastes
tastes right to me I guess yeah so tell
me a bit about in terms of the art let's
say I'm just curious about who you see
as your influences in the in the work
do you have influences are you you're
like I certainly do
um it I can remember at least when I was
doing green month that it was something
that that changed changed quite
frequently and like
I am like struggling to even even
remember some of the names right now I'm
thinking of artists and I can think of
their Arts
um
but I mean no big deal like is it more
is it coming from the world of
traditional art from fine art or or just
from Comics the guard was in a mix of
different influences lots of different
things one one that comes up to me that
was really big for me is Christoph
Blaine
um and he's he's a French artist
um that did I was first introduced to
him he did did part of um dungeon he was
part of the dungeon series and he is
just this really expressive very fluid
artist and I just loved his layouts I
love the way he like laid out pages and
the dynamism in his stuff
um and I remember that being a big
influence on when I was doing this
um
and there's other there's other artists
that names Escape me that affected like
how I was trying to like ink and stuff
like that
um
yeah no worries if you don't if you
don't remember that at the moment but
for sure the inking is is an important
part of the the style because it has it
really has this kind of loose fluid
feeling to it which which helps in the
this fluidity of the story itself that I
was saying where it's like it almost
feels like on the you could almost read
it's interesting because like if you
wanted to you could read the book and
like
15 minutes right you could just kind of
flip through but then you go back and
then you just slowly go through all the
all the subtlety of the the changes and
the character growing up and all these
little reactions and then you can spend
hours with it just going through so it I
mean it's it's interesting that a book
can be that way because I could I could
I could really see it like it just flows
like water all the way through yeah
yeah I love hearing that because that's
that's like my experience with it that's
one of the really satisfying experiences
of that is having this sense of like a
flow like the way like I did this thing
where when I would finish a section I
would kind of do it in chunks when I
would finish a section I would lay out
all the pages on my floor and like stand
up on my couch and just like yeah yeah
how all the pages
um kind of went together and
um
I love that way of thinking about Comics
I mean you can certainly think about
them as panel like each individual panel
but I love this idea that of the subtle
changes between each panel how each
panel connects and how it it becomes
this big hole
um and that was definitely a lie for me
with color like the coloring of this
book was something where I was thinking
very very carefully about how like color
like transition from from panel to panel
and how that kind of tied everything
together
[Music]
um
but yeah there's something about that as
far as like the flow of the story that
that just feels like really important to
me is particularly with this book yeah
well definitely I could I could
definitely see it you know
um and so yeah I think I think like for
me I'm just happy that the book exists
and I hope I really hope that that that
I mean if we don't see another green
monk book then at least something from
you because I because I I really think
it's it's wonderful
um and I encourage everybody to get it
look green monk it's it's you can get it
on Amazon it's very reasonable uh and
it's and it's yeah it's great for kids
too like even kids it's like good in my
my all my kids read it and they they
really liked it you know they didn't
have to you don't need like you you can
get all the subtlety of the changes but
you can also kind of read it as a fun
story about you know this this kind of
uh Rebel not rebellious but like
rambunctious young man who who kind of
finds his way so so thanks for thanks
for the book yeah yeah and I wish you
the best as you kind of figure it out
like what you're gonna do next yeah
thank you appreciate that that's
probably some more comics at some point
in the future yeah great